Nos encanta creer que la medicina clínica es, digamos, como la ingeniería mecánica.
Claro.
O sea, piensa en esto.
Apoyas el estetoscopio en el pecho de un paciente, escuchas un soplo sistólico y
activo,
y tu cerebro automáticamente dice, bueno, ahí está el problema.
Es nítido.
Exacto, es nítido, es reconfortante.
En la clínica nos gusta que las cosas sean así, de tangibles.
Sí, totalmente.
Y la verdad es que ese tipo de hallazgos nos dan una falsa sensación de que todo en
el examen físico es binario.
O lo escuchas o no lo escuchas.
Lo palpas o no lo palpas.
Pero hoy vamos a hacer un análisis profundo de la evidencia, usando nuestras
fuentes de medsemiotics y la base de medsemiotics-db, sobre
una situación clínica donde esa certeza mecánica desaparece por completo.
Así es.
Vamos a hablar de una condición que es, literalmente, una bomba de tiempo
estadística, y además completamente silente, el aneurisma de aorta abdominal.
Un tema fascinante y peligroso.
Muy peligroso. Y creo que lo más perturbador de esta inmersión en el razonamiento
clínico que haremos hoy es ver cómo tus propias manos te pueden
mentir en la cara.
Te mienten si no entiendes los números que hay detrás, claro.
Porque pone a prueba no solo tu técnica manual, sino todo tu razonamiento
probabilístico.
Exacto.
Las manos te dan información, sí.
Pero la forma en que el cerebro procesa esa información táctil en el abdomen es de
todo menos directa.
Y para que quienes nos escuchan, que seguramente están lidiando con esto en
medicina interna o urgencias, les saquen el mayor provecho, vamos a
estructurar esto de forma socrática.
Me parece perfecto.
Vamos a plantear preguntas, daremos un breve segundo para que ustedes hagan una
pausa mental e intenten responderlas.
Y luego desglosamos el porqué.
Vamos a ello.
Entonces, vamos directo a la realidad de la consulta.
Visualicemos este escenario típico de atención primaria.
Tienes a un paciente varón, 71 años,
acude a su control semestral por hipertensión arterial.
El hombre se siente fantástico.
Está completamente asintomático, cero dolor abdominal, cero dolor
lumbar, no reporta ningún tipo de cambio al esfuerzo.
La típica consulta de 15 minutos para renovar recetas.
Exacto. Y si miramos un poco más de cerca, fuma alrededor de
un paquete diario desde los 18 años.
Uy, factor de riesgo enorme.
Gigante. Y no lo ha dejado.
Además, hace seis años tuvo un infarto de miocardio.
Tiene un stent coronario y toma aspirina, una estatina por
hipercolesterolemia y dos antihipertensivos.
Todo un perfil vascular, digamos.
Así es. Físicamente mide 1,84.
Es bastante delgado. Su índice de masa corporal es de 23, con un
perímetro abdominal de 88 centímetros.
Delgado y alto.
Y signos vitales, pues, estables.
Presión en 146 sobre 84 y frecuencia cardíaca de 68
latidos por minuto. Dato clave, nunca se le ha hecho una ecografía abdominal.
Eso es importante retenerlo.
Y hay un fantasma familiar. Su hermano mayor fue operado de un aneurisma de aorta
abdominal hace tres años.
Ah, bueno, eso cambia las cosas.
Y aquí lanzo la primera pregunta socrática, para que quienes nos escuchan lo
piensen un segundo.
El paciente viene únicamente a controlar su tensión.
No le duele nada. ¿Por qué este es un buen momento para pensar en su aorta
abdominal?
Hagamos una pausa mental aquí.
Porque, a ver, jugando de abogado del diablo, en una consulta de 15 minutos, donde
el paciente viene súper bien, ¿no es buscar problemas donde no los hay?
Pues te diría que en este escenario específico, buscar el problema asintomático es
la definición misma de supervivencia.
¿Tan así?
Tan así. El aneurisma de aorta abdominal es súper traicionero.
Es una dilatación progresiva que no genera ningún síntoma hasta que ocurre
la complicación temida.
Que es la rotura.
Exacto, la rotura. Y esto tiene una altísima mortalidad.
Si tú esperas a que este hombre de 71 años te diga que tiene dolor lumbar súbito,
pues estadísticamente ya llegaste tarde.
Básicamente, si duele, ya perdimos el partido.
Literalmente. Y mira la evidencia de nuestras fuentes.
Este paciente es una bomba de tiempo estadística.
El tabaquismo activo aquí es el factor de mayor peso.
¿De cuánto estamos hablando?
La base documenta un odds ratio de 5.57.
O sea, casi 6 veces más riesgo, específicamente para aneurismas de 4.0
centímetros o mayores. Y con un intervalo de confianza del 95%
entre 4.24 y 7.31.
¡Guau! Y a eso hay que sumarle todo lo demás.
La edad, que es alto, la cardiopatía, la hipertensión y,
bueno, el hermano.
Claro, el antecedente familiar de primer grado por sí solo aporta un odds
ratio de 1.95. Te duplica el riesgo basal.
Ya veo. Y eso nos lleva a la segunda pregunta socrática para la audiencia.
Si buscamos en el artículo la probabilidad basal, la probabilidad antes
de tocarlo, ¿a qué pacientes y a qué aneurisma se refiere exactamente?
Exactamente.
Pensemos en esa probabilidad basal un momento.
Porque aquí siento que hay una trampa sutil en la evidencia.
Si revisas la base, te da un valor de 0.014, o sea, un 1.4%.
Ajá.
Y 1.4% suena bajísimo.
Suena a que no deberíamos ni estresarnos.
Bueno, suena bajo hasta que entiendes de dónde sale.
Esa cifra viene de un cribado masivo ecográfico en 73,451
veteranos.
Todos hombres.
Hombres, sí, de 50 a 79 años.
Pero el detalle crítico, el que te cambia todo, es que esa prevalencia
es exclusivamente para aneurismas de 4.0 centímetros o mayores.
O sea, no aplica para dilataciones menores.
Exacto. La fuente primaria no publica en su resumen la prevalencia para
los de 3.0 centímetros o mayores.
Claro, y si nuestra probabilidad de partida está atada a un tamaño físico tan
específico de 4 centímetros, eso va a condicionar matemáticamente todo lo que
hagamos con las manos a continuación en la camilla.
Por obligación matemática, así es.
Y aquí viene nuestra tercera pregunta socrática, para adentrarnos en la palpación.
Antes de poner las manos sobre el paciente, ¿qué pregunta responde exactamente a la
palpación y cómo afecta la fisionomía de nuestro paciente en particular?
Tómense un segundo para analizar la fisionomía.
Porque él mide 1.84 y es delgado.
Y eso es vital. A ver, la palpación no mide centímetros
exactos. Tus manos no son un calibrador.
Claro.
La maniobra solo responde a si la aorta parece más ancha de lo normal.
Y en cuanto a la fisonomía, pues este paciente es el escenario ideal.
Porque no tiene grasa abdominal.
Exacto. La fuente documenta que la obesidad abdominal es el modificador que
más reduce la sensibilidad de la maniobra.
Bien, entonces lo acostamos en la camilla, decúbito supino, le pedimos
que flexione las rodillas para relajar el abdomen, palpamos por encima del ombligo.
Con firmeza.
Con firmeza, sí. Y el hallazgo clínico exacto que documenta la fuente es, cito
textual, pulsación aórtica ensanchada a la palpación.
Ese es el signo.
Y aquí es donde mi intuición de médico empieza a pelear con la estadística.
Cuarta pregunta socrática. El artículo da dos cocientes de verosimilitud
positivos para este signo, un LR positivo de 12.0 y un
LR positivo de 15.6.
¿Qué significa eso?
Otra pausa para que la audiencia lo medita.
Porque mi intuición me dice, a ver, esto debe ser como el volumen de una radio.
Si el LR es 15.6, es porque el latido me empuja las manos con mucha
más violencia.
O lo siento más ancho que en el escenario del 12.0.
¿Es así?
Pues te entiendo perfecto, pero esa intuición es completamente falsa.
¿En serio?
En serio. Este es el punto contraintuitivo principal.
No son dos intensidades distintas del signo.
¿Entonces?
Es exactamente la misma maniobra y el mismo resultado táctil.
La diferencia está en contra de qué definición de enfermedad midieron los
investigadores esa maniobra.
A ver, explícame eso.
Mira, el LR positivo de 12.0, con su intervalo del
95% entre 7.4 y 19.5, es el
rendimiento para diagnosticar un aneurisma de 3.0 centímetros o mayor.
Ok.
Pero el LR positivo de 15.6 con intervalo entre
8.6 y 28.5 es para un aneurisma de 4.0
centímetros o mayor.
El rendimiento sube simplemente porque es más fácil que tu mano atrape un tubo más
grande.
¡Guau! Claro, no es que yo palpe diferente, es que el objetivo es más fácil de
chocar contra mis dedos.
Exactamente.
Pero entonces tenemos un problema de cálculo bayesiano, porque tenemos una
probabilidad basal de 1.4% y dos multiplicadores diferentes.
¿Cuál uso?
Y aquí es donde muchos se equivocan.
Como la probabilidad basal de 0.014 era para
aneurismas de 4 centímetros o más, por pura obligación matemática tienes
que usar el LR positivo de 15.6.
O sea, alinear peras con peras.
Exacto. Cruzar la prevalencia de 4 centímetros con el LR de 3
centímetros crearía un número sin ningún significado clínico real.
Un desastre matemático.
Totalmente. Y hay que aclarar algo.
Incluso usando el LR de 15.6, partiendo de una probabilidad tan baja
de 1.4%, no llegas a la certeza diagnóstica.
Seguimos bajos en probabilidad posprueba.
Sí. La fuente nos dice que el valor predictivo positivo en las series es solo del
43%.
O sea, menos de la mitad de las veces que palpas algo ensanchado realmente es un
aneurisma.
Así es. La palpación positiva indica ecografía.
Te dice ve a buscarlo, pero no diagnostica por sí sola de ninguna manera.
Y eso nos empuja a la otra cara de la moneda, que creo que es el peligro real en
urgencias o en la consulta.
Quinta pregunta socrática. ¿Qué hubiera pasado si la palpación de nuestro paciente
delgado resultaba negativa?
Piénsenlo muy bien.
Si yo hundo las manos y no siento nada, ¿puedo descartar el aneurisma y mandarlo a
su casa?
Rotundamente no. Jamás.
¿Por los LR negativos?
Por los LR negativos, que son malísimos.
El LR negativo para aneurismas de 3.0 centímetros o
más es de 0.72, con un intervalo de 0.65
a 0.81.
Eso no baja nada la probabilidad.
Nada. Y para los de 4.0 centímetros es de 0.51.
Sigue siendo muy pobre. Un LR negativo de 0.72 deja
tu duda casi intacta.
Pero ¿por qué somos tan malos palpando esto si no lo sentimos?
Por la sensibilidad desglosada por diámetro.
Para aneurismas pequeños, entre 3.0 y 3.9 centímetros,
la sensibilidad de tus manos es de apenas 0.29.
Detectamos menos de un tercio.
Menos de un tercio, así es. E incluso para masas gigantes, aneurismas de 5.0
centímetros o mayores, la sensibilidad es solo de 0.76.
Espera, casi un cuarto de los aneurismas enormes se escapan a la palpación.
Se escapan porque están pegados a la columna, detrás de asas intestinales,
gas, epiplón. Se esconden demasiado bien.
Y aquí quiero tocar un mito clínico que frena mucho a la gente que está en la
clínica. El miedo a palpar fuerte por si se rompe la aorta bajo tus manos.
Un clásico.
¿Qué nos dice la evidencia sobre ese miedo?
La fuente tiene una nota de uso explícita.
No se ha descrito que la palpación precipite la rotura.
Hay que palpar con firmeza, sin miedo, porque si palpas
superficialmente, esta sensibilidad malísima va a ser peor todavía.
Bien, entonces llegamos al momento de tomar decisiones.
Ya le hicimos la maniobra. Sexta pregunta socrática.
Mandamos la ecografía de confirmación y resulta que sí, tiene una aorta
infrarrenal de 4.6 centímetros con trombo mural sin complicaciones.
Bien.
Y aquí mi pregunta es, ¿la ecografía se pidió solo por la palpación positiva?
Les doy un segundo para responder esto mentalmente.
Porque la tentación es pensar que la palpación nos salvó el día.
Si no hubiéramos palpado, nos perdíamos un bulto de 4.6 centímetros.
Y ese es un error conceptual gigantesco.
¿Por qué?
Porque la ecografía estaba indicada de todos modos.
Ah, por los criterios de cribado.
Claro, un varón de 65 a 75 años con antecedente de
tabaquismo es candidato directo a cribado ecográfico.
Entonces la palpación positiva solo le dio prisa al asunto.
Añadió urgencia, pero, y esto es vital, una palpación negativa
jamás debió haber cancelado la ecografía debido a su pésimo LR
negativo.
Entendido. Y con este hallazgo de 4.6 centímetros, que está por debajo del umbral
típico de cirugía electiva, ¿cuál es nuestra conducta en atención primaria?
Pues primero se deriva a cirugía vascular para su seguimiento ecográfico.
Lógico.
Pero el tratamiento clínico empieza ahí mismo en tu consulta.
Hay que suspender el tabaco, que acelera el crecimiento y el riesgo de ruptura,
control estricto de la presión arterial y, claro, mantener su aspirina y estatina
por su cardiopatía isquémica.
Y supongo que avisarle a la familia.
Fundamental.
Hay que iniciar cribado en sus familiares de primer grado.
Recuerda que el hermano ya lo tuvo.
Totalmente.
Y para contrastar esto, quiero plantear una séptima y última pregunta
socrática. El escenario opuesto.
A ver.
Imagina un paciente que llega a urgencias.
Es obeso, 74 años, dolor lumbar súbito,
empapado en sudor y con hipotensión franca.
Un cuadro de shock.
Sí, shock. Le palpas el abdomen y la palpación aórtica es
negativa. ¿Qué hacemos?
Piénselo bien, quienes nos escuchan, porque aquí se juega en la vida del paciente.
¿Cambia algo esa palpación negativa?
En ese escenario, la palpación tiene un rol de exactamente cero.
Cero absoluto. La advertencia explícita de la base es que no
puede usarse para excluir, mucho menos si la rotura está en tu diagnóstico
diferencial.
Y menos si es obeso.
Menos si es obeso, porque ahí la sensibilidad baja todavía más.
En ese caso, avisas a cirugía vascular y le haces una ecografía a pie de cama o
una tomografía si está estable.
Ignoras tus manos por completo.
Excelente lección de humildad clínica.
Y con esto llegamos al final de este análisis profundo.
Si nuestra audiencia debe recordar una sola cosa mañana en la clínica, creo que es
el concepto contraintuitivo de la palpación.
Sí, que es una prueba de una sola vía, una prueba específica.
Exacto, de una sola vía.
Si hay pulsación aórtica ensanchada a la palpación, esto desplaza fuertemente tu
probabilidad hacia el diagnóstico por sus altos LR positivos.
Te enciende las alarmas.
Pero si es negativa, apenas descarta nada por un LR negativo muy
pobre.
Y la mayoría de aneurismas pequeños simplemente se te escapan.
Así es.
Y recalcar la lección epistemológica.
No se puede mezclar la probabilidad basal de una definición, la de 4 centímetros,
con el rendimiento de otra definición de 3 centímetros.
Hay que ser coherentes con la evidencia.
Definitivamente.
Y me gustaría terminar dejando un pensamiento final provocativo para quienes nos
escuchan sobre los límites de la evidencia.
Es un buen ejercicio.
Todo lo que hemos discutido hoy, todos estos números tan precisos, se basan en una
cohorte de veteranos masculinos de los años 90.
Completamente sesgado al sexo masculino.
La evidencia sobre la aplicación del cribado ecográfico y la prevalencia exacta en
mujeres está poquísimo representada en estas fuentes.
Y la biología puede ser distinta.
Así que la pregunta que les dejo es, ¿cómo ajustan ustedes este
rigor matemático? ¿Cómo calibran su intuición cuando la paciente que entra por la
puerta es una mujer y no encaja para nada en la cohorte del estudio original?
Queda para pensarlo.
Muchísimo para reflexionar.
Sin duda. Gracias por acompañarnos en esta inmersión.